Imagine, if you will, a town
just reeling from the echoes of
a recent massacre.
Its streets are now eerily
empty.
It's old leadership totally
swept away, replaced by the
stern, unyielding new authority.
Yeah, and there's this thick,
pervasive fear hanging in the
air.
You know, it's like a constant
companion to every whisper,
every shadow.
Exactly.
And this isn't just any town.
This is Valaki within its tense,
almost suffocating confines.
There's this desperate quest
unfolding, plans are
spectacularly unraveling, and
new destinies are colliding in
ways no one could have possibly
predicted.
Right.
So today you're joining us for a
deep dive into an adventure
session so packed with twists
and turns it honestly feels like
it's been ripped straight from
the pages of some gothic novel.
We've been sifting through
message dot TXT which is this
really detailed account of a
single intense session to try
and uncover the crucial
decisions, the dramatic events
and the unfolding mysteries that
are shaping these adventures
journey.
And our mission really for you
is to unpack the intricate
layers of this whole narrative.
We're going to try and
illuminate that fascinating,
often kind of frustrating
contrast between meticulous
planning and, well, absolute
chaotic execution.
Right, the best laid plans.
Exactly.
And those sudden, almost
whiplash inducing shifts in
fortune and the surprising,
often pretty desperate ways new
alliances can just pop up in the
shadow of this truly ancient
evil.
So what happens when our heroes,
or maybe given the, you know,
morally Gray situations they
keep finding themselves in,
maybe our anti heroes have to
navigate a world that seems
actively designed to thwart them
at every single turn?
Yeah.
How do they even cope?
All right, with that mission
clear, let's dive straight into
Valaki's grim new reality.
OK, so we open this session with
our surviving adventurers.
That's Radley, Traxador, and
Dermont returning to what should
be a familiar haven.
Right?
The Blue Water Inn.
Yeah, they're home base, sorta.
But right away, you can just
feel this profound shift in the
atmosphere, the tap room, which
they've surely seen bustling
before.
Lots of patrons chatter.
It's now eerily, uncomfortably
quiet.
Completely empty.
And this isn't just like an off
night for the local pub.
No, it's a stark symptom of
something much deeper, much more
chilling, gripping Valaki.
Definitely, The source tells us.
The townsfolk are basically
staying out of sight.
They're scarred, almost
traumatized by that recent
massacre during what was
supposed to be a celebration,
the Festival of the Blazing Sun.
Yeah, imagine the silence on the
Main Street.
Usually you'd hear hawkers,
villagers talking.
Yeah, now it's just maybe the
distant clang of a guard
patrol's armor.
It's unnerving.
The air itself feels colder,
sharper, like fear is just
frozen.
Everyone's breath shop windows
are shuttered.
Not just closed, but like bolted
tight almost defensively.
The whole town is holding its
breath.
Mirroring how the townsfolk are
retreating inward, you know,
maybe peeking out from behind
curtains at any sound.
It's not just quiet.
It's a town in mourning, gripped
by this intense, pervasive fear.
And the whole political
landscape totally upended.
There's a new regime in place.
Valachi's new burger mistress,
the town's appointed leader.
She's taken firm, almost
autocratic control.
And it's not a gentle
transition, is it?
The source calls it a severe
crackdown.
Right.
Curfews, public spaces,
deserted.
Those are the immediate,
tangible results.
It fundamentally reshapes
everything about daily life
there.
And if that wasn't enough to set
a somber mood, the source
explicitly mentions the death of
Soren Ironwood.
We can guess he was a
significant character just from
the mention.
Yeah, definitely.
And his death happened only 1/2
hour before this session even
starts.
So they're walking into a
freshly wounded city, still
bleeding from recent tragedies,
both public and, for them,
probably quite personal with
Soren.
It's a heavy start.
You can almost feel the weight
on their shoulders as they step
back into that in a stark
reminder that the stakes are
just constantly escalating in
Borovia.
That half hour detail, it's
incredibly potent, isn't it?
It means the immediate past
isn't just history.
It's still this raw, open wound,
A trauma unfolding in real time.
Exactly.
And it just amplifies that
pervasive mood of fear and
unease gripping the town.
We see it concretely curfews,
deserted streets.
It's oppressive.
You can feel it even just
hearing about it.
This new Burga mistress, she's
tightened her grip, right?
Strict rules, probably trying to
restore order, but maybe
inadvertently just layering more
fear onto an already terrified
population.
And it extends to the people to
fundamentally changing the
social fabric.
Even Danica, the innkeeper,
someone you'd expect to be, you
know, a welcoming face.
Like constant, yeah.
Now your regards new arrivals
Cooley, the source, says she's
openly suspicious of outsiders.
So it's not just the empty
streets, it's this deep shift in
human interaction.
Every glance, every whispered
word feels way laid down with
this new kind of caution.
It immediately sets that tone of
distrust, a community turning
inward, deeply wary of anything
or anyone new.
It's such a stark contrast to
what an inn usually represents,
a place of respite, camaraderie.
Now it's a place of quiet
scrutiny.
And that's why it matters so
much for our adventurers, right?
This new status quo completely
changes how they can operate in
balaki.
Absolutely.
In a city where every shadow
might hide an informant, where
public spaces are watched, where
even the innkeeper is
suspicious, usual methods
severely compromised.
Stealth, discretion, quick
thinking.
They're not just useful skills
anymore, they become absolutely
essential for survival, just to
achieve any objective without
drawing the really severe ire of
this new regime.
And if you connect this to the
bigger picture, it really
highlights how Borovia itself,
through its politics and the
fear it instills, actively
constrains and challenges anyone
trying to change things it.
Forces them to adapt or just get
crushed.
Yeah, demonstrating that ever
present, insidious nature of
Straud's influence, even in
seemingly mundane power shifts.
It's actually a very clever way
the narrative sets up immediate,
tangible stakes for every single
action they take.
Makes even a simple walk down
the street a potential gamble.
So OK, given all that immediate
danger, the recent loss, the
tension you can practically
taste in Valaki, you'd expect
our companions to be, well,
hyper focused on their next
immediate life saving move.
You really would Survival mode.
But here's a curious turn, the
source tells us they actually
take a moment to pause.
Right there, amidst this fresh
trauma and the city's grim
reality, they start reminiscing
about Madame Eva's tarot card
reading.
Which wasn't recent at all.
This is way back early days in
Borovia, a pivotal moment of
prophecy.
It's a surprising shift, isn't
it, to reflect on destiny amidst
such immediate chaos, Almost
like they're searching for
meaning, maybe reassurance, in a
world that feels increasingly
random and hostile.
It truly is, and it speaks
volumes about how pervasive fate
and mysticism are within
Borovia.
Even when immediate dangers loom
large, those bigger underlying
currents of destinies still
occupy their minds like a guy,
but also a source of constant
anxiety.
That's a very human impulse
though, isn't it?
When faced with overwhelming
randomness, you look for
patterns.
You want to believe there's a
bigger plan?
Definitely.
Now.
Derman, interestingly, is noted
as being perplexed by this turn
in the conversation, which
cleverly reveals he wasn't
actually there for that initial
reading.
So.
It's a way to fill him in.
Exactly.
It's not just a character
detail, it's a narrative device.
It lets Traxidor and Radley
recount the Vistani woman's
fortune telling for his benefit,
and by extension, for hours.
For you, the listener, it's our
chance to catch up on this
crucial piece of back story.
Vital exposition woven pretty
seamlessly into the dialogue.
And Radley doesn't just stop
there.
He also shares details about
Stanamir of Estani, You know,
one of those nomadic people
often serving as Strad's eyes
and ears across the land.
Right, a complicated
relationship.
And how his people's
relationship to Strad was
foretold.
So this isn't just simple
fortune telling anymore.
It hints at these deep seated,
complex loyalties.
Ancient packs, a history binding
certain groups like the Vistani
directly to the Land's dark
overlord.
Often fraught with manipulation,
maybe even grudging service.
It adds layers, doesn't it, to
what might otherwise seem like a
straightforward hero's journey.
It shows that alliances in
Barovia are rarely simple.
They often come with a hidden
cost or some terrible truth
attached.
So these prophecies, they're not
isolated events, they're threads
in a much larger tapestry,
constantly shaping how they see
things, what they expect.
Precisely.
And when they actually look at
the cards themselves, we see
this fascinating mix of
revelation and continued
mystery.
The source says they've already
identified the meaning of the
tax collector.
OK, so one down.
Yeah, this implies a past
success, maybe a quest
completed, a significant
revelation that's already moved
their larger adventure forward.
It indicates genuine progress in
this really daunting quest.
That must feel good at least
like validation.
A rare comfort in a land of
despair for sure, having that
foundational piece of the puzzle
in place.
But then you have the Bishop.
This card tracks it or knows
alluded to the Amber Temple,
which is this legendary super
dangerous place full of ancient
knowledge and dark secrets.
Right.
And he's still keen on finding
it.
He knows it's somewhere on Mount
Gacas, that towering,
treacherous peak at the southern
end of the valley.
But the exact location, and more
importantly, what secrets it
really holds still a mystery.
A tantalizing mystery.
It's a powerful long term goal,
isn't it?
Potential source of great power
or vital info just hanging over
them.
A beacon of what might be, if
they can only find it.
And then there's the Seer.
The party believes they've
successfully identified Ismak as
this fated companion.
OK, another piece seemingly
falling into place.
A prophecy fulfilled, maybe
confirming their path,
solidifying their current
allies.
A glimmer of hope.
They're not totally alone in
this fight.
But.
Then they hit a wall.
Uncertainty with the
Executioner, the Mercenary.
These cards, the source states,
remain frustratingly cryptic.
Meaningless for now.
Pretty much.
Their meaning is still too
obscure to give them any
practical guidance, at least
crucial aspects of their future
completely uncertain.
It's a powerful reminder, isn't
it?
Even with divine guidance, not
everything is revealed.
The most dangerous twists often
stay hidden until the very last
moment.
The striking thing here is how
these prophecies serve as both
guidance and mystery.
They provide direction.
They confirm past events and
alliances almost like a like a
divine road map, but they also
leave huge unknowns, forcing the
adventurers to make decisions
with incomplete information,
basically navigating a fog of
fate.
They know some things, just
enough to keep moving.
But the most dangerous, maybe
the most critical pieces of the
puzzle still veiled.
It's this constant, agonizing
tension between destiny and free
will.
Every step they take is an act
of faith or maybe defiance
against an unknown future.
And zooming out, the
implications for Borovia as a
whole are pretty profound.
This really highlights that
pervasive sense of
predestination, the supernatural
woven into the very fabric of
the land.
It's not just a random series of
encounters, it's a world where
even a simple card reading can
dictate destinies, where
characters are swept up and
forces much larger than
themselves.
Reinforces that gothic horror
element, suggesting the very
fabric of existence here is
woven with premonition and
ancient curses.
Your path to salvation or
damnation might already be laid
out, just waiting for you to
stumble onto it.
And this constant presence of an
unfolding prophecy, it also
hints at the narratives deep
roots in that tradition of
tragic, faded heroes adds a
layer of, well, sophisticated
literary depth to their whole
adventure.
So after this deep, almost
existential reflection on fate
and prophecy, the party finally
shifts focus back to something
more immediate, more concrete.
Back to reality.
Yeah, they decide to continue
their search for a wedding dress
for the Abbot.
Now the Abbot is this powerful,
really enigmatic figure in
Borovia, known for his strange
obsessions and maybe even
stranger experiments,
particularly with flesh columns.
Right, Not exactly your friendly
neighborhood cleric.
Not at all.
So this is quite an unusual
objective in itself, isn't it?
It implies this ongoing, perhaps
strange, obligation they have to
this powerful yet deeply
disturbing figure.
It really does.
But as you're thinking about it,
Dearmond has what the source
calls a crucial aha moment.
Oh yes, a critical insight that
you know, in retrospect, could
have saved them a lot of
trouble.
It suddenly occurs to Damon that
if the Reeve was emptying the
house, the dress might have
simply been in the wagon outside
the Reeves headquarters the
whole time.
Oh.
Man, you mean they might have
stirmed the Manor confronted the
Reeves for nothing if they just
checked the wagon first?
Possibly this single realization
implies they might have entirely
circumvented a dangerous
confrontation.
It's that classic case of
hindsight being 2020, a moment
of just profound frustration,
realizing they might have
already completed a difficult
task if only they'd considered
this simpler path earlier.
OK, so armed with this belated
but vital info, they make a
quick decision.
They're going to waylay the
wagon, search for the dress.
Simple enough, right?
Seems like it.
They even presume it would go to
Lady Walker's house.
She's that powerful, subtly
menacing noblewoman known for
her loyalty.
Distraught.
So this suggests Lady Walker is
a known quantity, a potential
adversary, or at least someone
they need to keep tabs on.
Right, so the initial plan is
pretty straightforward.
Ambush the wagon as it passes.
Seems logical, maybe even
strategically sound.
Logical, perhaps, but fatally
flawed in its execution, which,
let's be honest, often happens
in Barovia when plans meet
reality.
Tell me about it.
The source details this classic
problem with group dynamics.
The party starts squabbling in
circles over the plans details.
Analysis paralysis.
Totally.
This isn't just a minor
disagreement.
This infighting and indecision
directly leads to their
immediate, almost embarrassing
failure while they argue,
debating the perfect angle, the
optimal timing, all the
contingencies.
The wagon just passes right by
the end, completely unnoticed by
the bickering adventurers.
It's almost comical, and it's
tragic irony, a perfect
illustration of how getting
bogged down in hypothetical
details can be more dangerous
than just acting.
Their focus blinded them to the
present reality it.
Truly is, and it's only Danica,
the innkeeper who snaps them
back to reality, Points out the
wagon through a window and
outside intervention, breaking
through their self-imposed
paralysis.
It highlights how deeply
engrossed they were in their own
unproductive bickering, almost
oblivious.
But even then, there's no
cohesive group action.
Instead, Derman abruptly leaps
up.
Just goes for it.
Rushes from the inn, pursuing
the wagon alone, up the street
towards Lady Walker's mansion.
It's impulsive, almost
instinctual, probably borne from
frustration and wanting to fix
their collective failure
immediately.
And quite a determined move.
He cuts a corner, shows
impressive agility, closes the
distance fast, but the wagon
stays tantalizingly just out of
reach, pulled by its horses at a
good clip.
In a last ditch, adrenaline
fueled effort, he leaps and
catches the tailgate moments
before it arrives at the mansion
gates.
Pure rogue agility and sheer
desperation, a testament to his
individual resourcefulness.
Then he breathlessly scrambles
underneath the chassis, finds
his precarious hiding spot just
as the teamster dismounts to
tend to the horses, quick
thinking under immense pressure,
finding concealment in the nick
of time.
Now he's right there, hidden in
plain sight.
The striking thing here,
narratively, is that dramatic
contrast.
You've got the group stalled,
ineffective planning, all that
talking in circles,
overthinking, and then Derman's
immediate, chaotic, incredibly
physical response.
While the others were lost in
hypotheticals, Derman acted.
He abandoned the flawed plan,
embraced cure improvisation.
It's not just about his
personality.
It's maybe a profound
observation about survival in
Borovia.
Sometimes the sheer will to just
do something, seize A fleeting
opportunity.
Trump's meticulous but slow
deliberation.
Yeah, it really poses that
deeper question about heroism in
this dark land.
Is true success here often just
a matter of chaotic adaptation
rather than rigid foresight?
So Dermont's clinging under the
wagon, hidden from the Teamster.
He's got a moment right?
His initial hope may be a
flicker of conventional thinking
is the Teamster will just go
inside, leave the wagon right
for the taking.
Makes sense?
Less confrontation.
But of course, in Barovia,
nothing's ever that easy.
The Teamster stubbornly stays
outside right by the wagon,
maybe enjoying the quiet, Who
knows, But it forces Derman to
change tactics on the fly.
Meanwhile, Radley and Traxidor,
who left the inn behind Derman,
They're quickly outpaced.
Their cautious approach now
leaves them way behind.
Yeah, they're trying to stay
inconspicuous, stealthing behind
houses, which really highlights
their more measured approach
compared to Derman's
impulsiveness.
It's like a classic divergent in
adventuring style isn't?
It totally so Derman, in his
desperation, turns to magic, but
subtly.
He casts Minor Illusion, that
simple spell creating a sensory
figment to make the sound of a
bear right behind the horses.
A bear.
OK, bold move.
The immediate effect is exactly
what he hoped for.
The Teamster is startled,
totally unprepared for that
sound, and the horses already
skittish in this tense town.
They spook violently, leaving
their harnesses.
The wagon jolts forward a few
feet, just enough to create that
window with that slight,
unexpected momentum.
Derman then casts Mage Hand, the
spell with a spectral
disembodied hand.
Right from manipulating things
remotely.
Exactly.
He uses it to release the wheel
brake and just like that the
wagon starts lumbering into
motion.
And that's when the real, pure
chaos begins.
The frantic horses, now
terrified and with the break
off, immediately pull the wagon
wildly down the street.
German's just clinging to the
undercarriage for dear life as
it speeds up, the source says.
Maybe only three wheels are on
the ground.
Sometimes it's being tossed so
violently by the uneven
cobblestone.
Oh man, just picturing that.
It's pure danger.
Every bump could throw them off.
And to emphasize the sheer
mayhem, periodically things are
flying out of the back chairs,
paintings crashing onto the road
with these sickening thuds.
It illustrates the destructive
force of this out of control
vehicle.
And the Teamster.
Left Behind tries to run after
it, shouting probably, but he's
quickly outpaced Left in the
dust and wreckage, just
bewildered frustration.
OK, so Derman's created this
chaos.
He's on this wild ride.
What next?
This is where Derman, despite
his impressive agility and quick
thinking so far, makes a crucial
miscalculation.
He figures he's gained enough
distance from the mansion and
the Teamster.
Thinks he's clear, yeah.
So he casts Mage Hand again,
trying to reset the wagon's
handbrake.
His intention is probably to
bring it to a controlled,
discreet stop, secure his prize.
Right, makes sense.
But his calculation is
catastrophically off.
The wheels lock up with this
sickening screech.
For a moment, the wagon Peters
violently left rights dramatic,
agonizing pause.
Then with brutal splintering
force it Jack nice and turns
over right in the middle of the
road.
And the consequences?
Devastating.
I imagine the source paints A
grim picture.
It's.
Truly grim, the remaining
contents are tossed everywhere
amidst splintered wood, broken
spokes, but the most
heartbreaking details the fate
of the horses, the.
Poor animal.
Violently jerk to a halt mid
stride by the jackknifing wagon
tumbling over onto the street.
The source mentions ribs,
spines, legs snapping from the
impact.
It's brutal, visceral, a tableau
of broken life and shattered
ambition, all for a wedding
dress.
Yet amidst this carnage,
Dermont's agility saves him
again.
Yeah, he's thrown from beneath
the wagon, but due to his rogue
skills, lands with only minor
abrasions and contusions.
Miraculously escaped serious
injury.
And after shaking off the crash,
what does he do?
A moment of unexpected mercy
actually shines through.
He sees the maimed horses
neighing, whinnying in agony,
clearly suffering.
Takes pity.
Yeah, flicker of compassion.
In the grim aftermath, he draws
his dagger, delivers a swift end
to their suffering.
It's a small act amidst the
chaos he caused, but it reveals
a layer of his character, maybe
a moral compass, still somewhat
intact even when his methods are
so destructive.
And then, amidst the wreckage,
the mud.
Streak of luck, he finally spots
it.
Lady Volakovich's wedding dress
is objective, lying relatively
intact in the muddy St.
But the clock's ticking, right?
The crash must have drawn
attention.
Exactly.
He hears villagers coming,
shouts, footsteps getting
closer.
Derman, ever the opportunist,
quickly gathers the dress, his
prize, and makes a hasty,
discreet withdrawal, melts into
the shadows, escapes with his
objective as the full
consequences of his actions,
this public spectacle of
destruction begin to unfold
behind him, now firmly linked to
the mysterious strangers in
town.
So the profound implication
here?
Durman succeeds.
He gets the dress, but at this
significant, highly visible
cost.
Absolutely.
The Rex wagon, the dead horses,
the public chaos, it all
highlights the destructive
nature of these impulsive
actions, even if driven by a
clear objective.
Or in this case, this strange
good intention for the Abbot.
And it's not just about the
moral cost of the horses.
It's the ripple effect, isn't
it?
The heightened authority of the
bergamistress, the increased
fear among the townsfolk, this
public spectacle, it actually
makes their next objective,
whatever it is, even harder.
That's a subtle but pervasive
truth in Borovia, isn't it?
Even a win can be a loss in
disguise.
You end up building the very
walls of oppression you're
trying to dismantle, escalating
the scrutiny and danger you
face.
OK, so while all this explosive
chaos is unfolding with Derman's
heist completely unbeknownst to
him and the others, a new,
equally significant thread
starts weaving itself into the
narrative.
A different perspective.
Yeah.
A diminutive stranger approaches
Valaki.
This is Yurihorn Tenpenny, a
halfling beast master, master of
animals.
Wilderness survival.
Usually has a loyal animal
companion.
His arrival immediately signals
a shift, A new piece entering
this already complex board.
And he's a cautious observer
right from the start.
Got that?
Hunter's keen eye working
already surveying the heavenly
guarded gates.
Your horn notes the palisade
walls are way too tall to climb.
Immediately forces him to
consider a more conventional,
but still dangerous entry.
And the welcome wagon isn't
exactly friendly.
Not at all.
The real grim welcome comes from
his observation of all those
wolf heads stuck on Pikes
outside the gate, A stark,
brutal warning about the dangers
within the savage nature of this
land, a clear message from the
local powers.
The whispers to this slinking
beast accompany him, which then
bounds off towards the tree
line.
Hints at his Beastmaster skills,
his strategic mind moving his
companion out of sight as he
prepares to enter.
So he approaches the gate,
announces himself.
You're a Horn Tenpenny from
Falconea, that realm known for
its harsh military regime,
aggressive expansionism.
And the guards?
Typically brutal and dismissive.
They laugh at him, suggest he
join a circus.
Casually mentioned nearby
Vestani with a big tent.
It's dismissive, but also
ironically kind of informative.
Gives your horn potential leads.
Highlights the local disdain for
outsiders.
But he's undeterred.
He bribes his way in, pays a
steep price, which immediately
establishes Volaki as a place
hard to enter without
significant personal cost.
And the guards then warn him
he'll need the Reeves permission
to leave, solidifying Volakis
Rep Not just as hard to get
into, but as a trap.
Escape isn't guaranteed.
A prison disguised as a town.
So once inside, your horn
wanders the vacant streets, sees
the same oppressive emptiness,
Derman and the others noted, the
silence, the fear, almost
tangible.
From a few weary passersby, he
quickly learns about the town's
strict curfew.
The burger mistresses severe
crackdown rapidly gets a handle
on the oppressive atmosphere
defining Vlaki's new reality.
He's quick to adapt, quick to
learn the rules of his grim new
game, Survivor's Instinct
kicking in.
And eventually, he finds his way
to the Blue Water Inn, the known
Nexus of activity.
Or at least where activity might
happen.
And just like with the others,
Danica the innkeeper regards
your horn.
Cooley, openly suspicious of
this newcomer, reinforces that
pervasive distrust solidifies
the inn's transformation from
welcoming haven to place of wary
scrutiny.
But despite Danica's frosty
reception, your horn soon makes
a crucial acquaintance.
Rick Tabio, the entertainer.
And Rick Tabio is immediately
intrigued.
Recognizes your horn as a fellow
Miss Walker, someone who's
traversed those mysterious
reality bending myths
surrounding Barovia that trap
outsiders.
Instantly sets them apart from
the locals.
Kindred spirits, maybe, if not
allies yet.
And You're a Horn is remarkably
bold about his origins, not
discreet about being from
Falkovnia, and more
significantly, states his clear,
vengeful objective seek
vengeance on Strode von
Zarevich.
Wow, just lays it out there,
immediately establishes his
motivations, the incredibly high
stakes of him being in Borovia.
He's not just passing through.
Nope.
Rakavio, sensing the importance
of this, may be recognizing a
powerful, if reckless potential
ally, invites Euro Horn to his
room for a private, more
discreet discussion away from
prying eyes and ears, especially
Strode spies.
And here's where we get one of
the most thrilling reveals of
the whole session.
After swearing Eurohorn to
absolute secrecy, Rick Tavio
performs this dramatic reveal.
Removes his hat.
And his appearance shimmers,
changes right before Eurohorn's
eyes.
Face becomes leaner.
Older attire shifts from
Vagabond ringleader to something
more like an itinerant
schoolmaster.
He apologizes for the deception,
explains discretion is
absolutely necessary to hide
from Straud's countless spies.
They're everywhere.
Then he reveals his true name,
Rudolf Ven Richten.
Rudolf Ven Richten and for you
rehorn the halfling, this name
is instantly recognized.
A gasp worthy moment.
Absolutely, he knows it.
Renowned Monster Hunter from
Darkon, a land shrouded in its
own ancient terrors, immediately
elevates his encounter to
monumental significance.
This isn't just an entertainer,
this is a living legend, a
figure synonymous with fighting
the very evils plaguing Borovia.
So they talk for a while,
establishing shared purpose.
Yeah, promising each other aid
in their mutual desperate
endeavor against Strad.
This is a critical alliance
forming, built on shared
knowledge in this common,
fearsome enemy.
Then Richton, with his vast
experience, must offer some
critical wisdom, insights honed
over years of dangerous work.
He does explains the typical
vampire weaknesses, knowledge
most hunters would prize, but
quickly warns Strad is far more
powerful than any ordinary
undead.
How so?
He's aided by the land itself,
it's beasts, even the Vastani.
Plus, he's a capable
necromancer, a truly formidable,
almost unbeatable foe.
So your horn expresses his goal,
looking for allies to take
vengeance.
Right.
But Van Richten, true to his
methodical, cautious nature,
declines the implied offer of an
immediate alliance, says he
hasn't yet developed a full,
comprehensive strategy to defeat
the vampire Lord, deems it too
early to act.
Shows his meticulous approach.
Contrasts sharply with the
impulsiveness we've seen.
Underscores the immense
challenge Straud represents.
Exactly.
And then comes the critical
warning, a moment of profound
foreshadowing.
Van Richten warns Yuri Horn to
stay clear of a group of
recently arrived adventurers,
clearly meaning Radley, Traxidor
and Dermont.
Wait, he warns them against
them.
Yes, he suspects they may even
be spies of Strawd, saying they
indicated A willingness to aid
vampires.
A grave accusation.
This is a massive red flag for
you, the listener, and for your
horn who's just stumbled into
this incredibly complex,
dangerous whag of alliances and
betrayals.
Wow, and as your horn leaves.
Vin Richton offers a practical
boon, a potion of greater
healing, a small but significant
gesture of goodwill aid for his
dangerous mission.
So, zooming out, what does this
all mean for the narrative?
This introduction of Rudolf von
Richten?
It's an absolute game changer.
No question, his deep knowledge
of Strad, his cautious,
strategic approach, they
contrast so sharply with the
often chaotic, impulsive actions
of the adventurers we've been
following.
Adds a layer of seasoned
professional monster hunting to
their amateur, often desperate
efforts.
And his specific warning about
Dermont's group creates immense
dramatic tension and
foreshadowing.
You've got this renowned Monster
Hunter, the expert advising our
new character to avoid the very
people we've been following
questioning their loyalties,
even suggesting they might be
agents of the enemy.
It sets up a fascinating
conflict, potential betrayal,
completely alters our perception
of the existing party cast, this
long shatter of doubt over their
intentions, their actions.
It's a masterful stroke of
narrative, weaving immediate
high stakes drama and profound
mistrust right into the story's
fabric.
So we have all these threads in
motion now, just spiraling
towards this dramatic
convergence.
Derriman, fresh from his
spectacularly chaotic success
with the wedding dress, makes a
swift, discreet return to the
Blue Water Inn, probably feeling
quite pleased with himself
despite the carnage of the
horses and wagon.
Yeah, objective achieved right
in his mind.
Maybe.
And it's right upon his return
that paths converge, a fateful
intersection.
He sees your horn.
Tenpenny, who has just come down
the stairs from Venrichten's
room, likely still processing
those monumental revelations,
still reeling from meeting a
legend.
This moment is absolutely
charged with dramatic irony.
Almost painful in its
anticipation for us, knowing
what we know.
Derriman, ever quick to assess,
instantly recognizes the
Hafling's campaigners attire,
sign of a fellow traveler, maybe
a warrior.
They quickly make acquaintances,
finding common ground in this
tense, unwelcoming town.
What makes this so compelling
and tragically ironic is that
Van Richty's crucial warning
about these adventurers
potentially being Strad's spies
is either forgotten in the rush
of meeting a new companion, or
maybe deliberately dismissed by
Eurohorn.
Maybe he values the potential
ally right now more than a vague
caution.
Could be, but it creates
immediate dramatic irony for
you, the listener, who knows the
full terrible context of that
warning.
So Derman and your own quickly
become associates.
Derman says he's waiting for his
friends return, completely
unaware of the perilous
situation they are in right now.
And Speaking of peril, while
Derman is safely back at the
inn, oblivious, your horns
warning forgotten, Radley and
Tracidor having a very
different, very dire experience.
Yeah, the flip side of the coin.
They finally arrive at the
wreckage of the wagon, still
trying to be cautious behind the
houses, trying to see if Derman
is in the crowd that's gathered
around the crash site.
But it's not them who spot
Derman.
Oh no.
It's the mob of of bystanders
drawn by the chaos who spot
Traxador and Radley first.
Oh, bad luck.
Someone yells the dreaded words.
It is the strangers that the
Burgo Mistress is looking for.
And just like that, boom,
they're no longer cautious
observers.
They are instant targets.
The public spectacle Dermont
created is now coming back to
haunt his unsuspecting
companions.
The chase begins immediately, a
frantic, desperate flight.
Instantly, a group of vigilantes
eager to earn the burger
mistresses favor, or maybe just
lash out of those they perceive
as the cause of their fear
charges.
After them, Bradley and Tracidor
are forced to turn tail, run N
up the street.
Their only hope?
The Northgate with the angry mob
hot on their heels.
It's a swift, brutal turn of
offense, a direct, devastating
consequence of the public
spectacle Dermont's heist
created.
Their earlier caution trying to
stay inconspicuous, meaningless
now in the face of an enraged,
terrified populace.
At the gate their desperation
becomes helpable.
They see a small continued of
guards, another warden will
sprinting Tracidor thinking fast
pregnant offers them money,
hopes to bribe his way out,
escape Valachi's tightening
grip.
Does it work?
A long shot, maybe.
Nope.
The Warden, clearly loyal, may
be emboldened by the mob and the
new regime.
Severity just sneers, retorts
with this chilling finality that
he'll have his money when he is
dead.
Chilling underscores the
absolute authority, the
ruthlessness, of the new Vlachi.
Radley tries a different tactic,
throws coins into the mob,
hoping to distract or deter
them.
Scatter them with greed maybe?
Buys them a second.
Doesn't work, only fuels their
desire to earn the burger
mistresses favor makes them even
more fervent in their pursuit.
It's a total lose lose
situation.
Every attempted solution just
deepens their predicament.
So the fight breaks out, a
desperate, unequal struggle.
The melee is joined.
Despite the adventurers inherent
skill at arms, they're proven
combat prowess.
The Valaki militia and the
enraged mob are simply too
numerous.
An overwhelming tide of bodies
and anger.
But they must put up a fight.
Oh yeah, the source confirms
their skill.
Several guards are slain, a half
dozen vigilantes dispatched by
Traxidor's powerful Thunder Wave
spell.
That burst of concussive force
that pushes enemies back shows
their fighting ability.
They can inflict significant
damage.
Traxidor also uses healing magic
to deflect injury, showing his
resilience.
The.
Sheer numbers.
Sheer numbers overwhelm them.
The mob just pummels them
mercilessly until they finally
fall beneath their feet,
unconscious, utterly defeated,
captured by the very town they
were trying to navigate.
The brutal defeat illustrating
that even the most skilled
adventurers can be brought down
by overwhelming force,
especially in a hostile place
like Falaki where the populace
itself becomes an enemy.
And the news spreads like
wildfire, I assume, in a tense,
insular town like that.
Exactly.
The word of the brawl, the
chase, the capture of these
strangers quickly echoes across
Falaki.
Sometime later, back at the Blue
Water Inn, Danica, now frantic,
clearly shaken, rushes into the
tap room.
To tell Derman.
Yells to Derman, delivering the
devastating news his friends
Radley and Tracks Door have been
captured by the Burger
Mistress's soldiers.
The consequences of the earlier
Chaos Derman's impulsive heist
have finally caught up and
Derriman, with his newly formed,
highly ironic alliance with
Eurohorn, is now left holding
the bag, facing an impossible
dilemma.
This isn't just a question of
what Derriman and Eurohorn will
do now, it's how this crisis
will define their characters,
their brand new alliance.
Right.
That dramatic irony of Van
Richten's warning, totally
ignored by Eurohorn, who's now
allied with one of the very
individuals Van Richten
cautioned him against.
Combined with the swift, brutal
capture of the others, it sets
the stage for a truly
precarious, unpredictable
future.
Will your horns trust in Dermont
even survives this?
What does it say about the
dangers of forging alliances in
a land where mistrust is often
the safest bet?
And what kind of impossible
choices will they face knowing
their comrades are now at the
mercy of the Lockies new
ruthless regime?
The stage is set for an epic,
potentially deadly
confrontation.
Loyalties tested, the true cost
of their actions becoming
painfully clear.
Hashtag out.
Wow, what a session, huh?
From that meticulously re
evaluated tarot reading offering
both guidance and just
frustrating mystery, to a
spectacularly chaotic wagon
heist ending in that dramatic
crash and, well, moral
ambiguity.
Definitely ambiguity.
To the surprising, highly
significant entrance of Rudolf
van Richten, the renowned
Monster Hunter.
And finally, the shocking
capture of two key adventurers.
This deep dive has truly shown
us that fine line between
triumph and disaster, and how
swiftly fortunes can turn in the
treacherous lands of Barovia,
where every victory can carry
some hidden unforeseen costs.
And you've seen how quickly
alliances can form and crumble,
how good intentions can lead to
devastating unintended
consequences, and how a well
meaning critical warning can be
totally ignored, leading to
immediate, perilous outcomes.
So with Radley and Traxidor are
now in the Burgo Mistress's
clutches, imprisoned by the very
authority they were trying to
evade, what does this mean for
the newly forged alliance
between Derriman and Yurihorn?
Yeah.
Will Yurihorn realize the
gravity of Van Richten's warning
too late?
Or will a shared enemy maybe
solidify their bond?
And what role will Rudolf van
Richten, with his deep knowledge
and profound suspicions,
ultimately play in their
unfolding story as these forces
of fate and consequence
converge?
The stage is set for an epic and
potentially deadly confrontation
where the very concept of trust
is basically a weapon.
So what will you do next,
knowing what you now know about
the perils and alliances of
Valaki?